first we turn once again to the ever
weak frail
cognitive mess that is all things joey
biden and sippy cup
anyway as cases of covert 19 have
sharply declined thankfully
americans they're trying to make up for
lost time beca becoming more active than
ever
by the way don't hold your breath
they'll never give president trump
credit for operation warp speed
uh no power hungry democrats the corrupt
media mob
they're not capable of it don't hold
your breath and meanwhile
well sippy cup joe is
not very active very few public events
an extremely early bedtime
constant weekend trips to delaware we
assume sleeping
and joe seems unwilling and unable and
incapable of rising to the occasion
this is getting to be a real clear
obvious danger
and now we have with the pandemic waning
joe's running out of excuses
the media mob trying to put a spin on
biden's obvious struggles
americans we can see with our own eyes
what's happening remember fake news cnn
they first described
sippy cup as an early to bed type who
enjoys a warm
fire in the oval office fireplace then
last week the new york
toilet paper times reporting that biden
is prone to outbursts
he's very moody gets very confused by
acronyms and
needs extensive preparation for any
public event
and then today the washington post even
they admitted
quote biden's public schedule can seem
notably like compared to his
predecessors and then
quote a lid meaning no public activities
that's often called very early in the
day as a very
light workload we should all be so lucky
and the post revealing that biden heads
to his private residence
all around six or seven to begin his
betty time routine
which i assume involves warm cookies
warm milky and sippy cup and maybe if
he's good at night night story
and of course the washington post
attempted to whitewash all of this
by highlighting biden's alleged
weightlifting routine
all right let's take a look at this joe
pump and iron all right you go
joe good good joe very good job joey
anyway the only problem is that video
that's from six years ago in 2015
and tonight it's extremely doubtful that
joe
is capable of such a routine remember we
were the ones that told you you know we
were told by everybody
that the wind blew him over three times
it was very windy days he was climbing
the stairs to air force
one not once not twice but three times
the wind blew him over very windy day
according to press secretary jen circle
back saki
biden well has so much energy and vigor
she claims she can barely keep up with
joe
wow take a look what more can you tell
us about the
president's um health regime we hear
he's lifting weights
what sort of weights is he lifting does
he have a personal trainer and what
happened to his
peloton bike did he bring it to the to
the white house
i didn't know where this was going um
but i'm intrigued by it um
i i will say i have nothing to read on
the president's uh
private exercise regime uh but i can
tell you having traveled
with him a fair amount um sometimes he's
hard to keep up with
really jen that might be the biggest lie
from the white house ever uh you must be
in serious decline
because jen no american would have a
tough time keeping up with joe's
schedule
clearly what we see today is not the
same joe biden of 2008 2012
even 2016 but you know what don't take
my word for it
as our old friend the great sportscaster
warner wolf would always say
let's go to the videotape you decide
in our bilateral relationships with
nations with whom we deal and have
serious trade deficits we have to be
willing to put more
cards on the table now they got a new
plan trust me
it's not going to cost you any more
folks follow your instincts on this one
they put one foot in front of the other
they keep going that's the unbreakable
spirit
of the people of america we hold these
truths to be self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the
you know the thing i want to thank the
the former general i keep calling in
general my
my the guy who runs that outfit over
there
visit vaccines.com.gov
vaccines.com or text to
your text your zip code to 438829
yeah putin president xi kim jong-un the
mullahs in iran
they see what you see not good joe now
has trouble remembering names and dates
he struggles with complex details he
often loses his train of thought
mid-sentence quickly now becoming
irritable and at times it appears that
sippy cup
is having trouble even walking and
listen to this from the washington post
quote
senator chris coons long-time biden
confidante said
that biden in meetings just crosses his
arms puts his chin in his hand
and then just listens i don't know
exactly who is steering the ship
but it's not that guy and it's obviously
not going well
and they're trying to hide it from the
rest of the world but we can see through
it
look at the country in just a few short
months
inflation 4.2 percent the highest in
13 years steel that's up a whopping 30
percent
copper 32 percent lumber great you want
to buy a 2x4
you're paying now 130 more than you were
last year
poultry beef consumption of any food and
that you buy at any grocery store any
drugstore
you are paying more for everything oil
and gas
on the way up that means everything
that's trucked to every location where
you shop
guess what they're passing that on to
you corporate
corporations they don't pay taxes you
will pay the new taxes there too
everything we now buy everything you buy
is more expensive look at forbes
83 percent of americans now tightening
their belts
because of joe's inflation also
a crisis in america's major cities after
handing out get out of jail free cards
with the so-called bail reform
defunding and talking about dismantling
police
well there's now a major crime wave all
across the country
now this weekend typical weekend in
chicago
54 people were shot 12 killed
shootings are up 36 percent from their
record last year in the windy city
that didn't stop chicago from releasing
94 people charged with murder
they let them back out on the streets
now since biden took office america has
now become more dangerous
a lot more expensive and a lot less
secure as
our enemies and countries that hate our
guts are taking full advantage
and some never trump or republicans
apparently they still
prefer sippy cup joe peggy noonan nice
lady
she's giving a speech at the reagan
library an event called a time for
choosing
i'm assuming here she's going to try to
move the republican party
away from president trump the maga
agenda
the america first agenda peggy
respectfully
the america first agenda the make
america great again agenda
will be the republican party agenda or
old establishment political candidates
will be defeated that's my prediction
i know you're a never trumper but it's
really not
complicated and i'm a registered
conservative but
if the gop wants to win they want to win
elections
they need to be the party of liberty
freedom
capitalism and our constitution that's
simple that includes the first amendment
and the second amendment
the party of gop needs to be the party
low taxes limited government
why so businesses can thrive and prosper
and hire people
not government bureaucrats we need to be
the party of school
choice so our children can compete in
the global economy
all children not just the ones fortunate
enough
to be born into privilege or be born in
a red state where they'll do much better
now of course the republican party if
they want to win they've got to offer
free market solutions for health care
that includes and protects pre-existing
conditions
republican party if they're to win
they've got to be putting
constitutionalists
on the bench not judicial activists
they've got to be the party that
restores law and order
so every american can pursue happiness
and safety and security
secure the border the party of energy
independence free and fair trade
peace through strength that's the agenda
peggy
are you a conservative or not you really
don't need to write a long speech here
anyway maybe you want to help out oh joe
biden and the new green deal socialists
well or maybe you can stick with joe or
stick with the 75 million people that
believe in america first
now you're right it is a time for
choosing and that agenda i laid out
is the conservative agenda that works
for the american people
the republican party if they want to be
relevant that's the agenda
that's the agenda i choose and i believe
that's the agenda most americans will
choose
now you're always free to vote for the
socialists like joe biden
and the squad or you can join other
never trump republicans and pick up your
toys throw a tantrum
stay home or run an establishment figure
that
just helps people like joe get elected
that's your choice
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else